hi teachers did you think khan academy  was only just for math i'm kristen  deservo the chief learning officer at  khan academy here to tell you about the  all-new middle school science content  we've added just in time for back to  school from climate to genetics our new  biology and earth and space science  courses offer hundreds of exercises and  articles that are aligned to next  generation science standards supplement  your instruction with over 60 new videos  presented by a diverse group of experts  and creators at this level students are  ready for rigorous and challenging  material so unlock your students  potential with fun and engaging  exercises that help them not only  understand the learning content but  teach them how to practice and apply it  it's all mastery learning based and like  everything else on khan academy it's all  free discover a whole new universe of  learning content and visit the link  below  [Music]